en mettant la main sur les 4000 films du
studio mgm amazon et son service de
visionnement frappe fort amazon ne
cessent de frapper des grands coups
notamment depuis le début de la pandémie
ça va obliger les autres joueurs à se
repositionner temps d en 1924
le studio hollywoodien métro goldwyn
mayer et derrière de grands films comme
autant en emporte le vent
2001 l'odyssée de l'espace et le
magicien d'oz là avec l'achat de mgm
mais c'est sûr que ça devient des
joueurs majeurs de l'industrie
audiovisuelle nord américaine en
particulier en achetant mgm pour la
somme de 8 milliards quatre cent
cinquante millions de dollars américains
la plateforme de visionnement amazon
prime vidéo obtient catalogue important
de films et entre autres les franchises
de workit de james bond et de la syrie
la servante écarlate c'est ça qui est
important c'est qu'on met le grappin sur
des propriétés intellectuelles et ça ça
vaut énormément d'argent
rocchi ont pu ressortir ce à tout moment
y aura toujours un prétexte et jeans
bande basse et inusable
la preuve un nouveau film qui sort à
l'automne avec ses 200 millions
d'abonnés à travers le monde
amazon prend vidéo veut s'imposer
davantage il a sur la fiche vraiment
très clairement les ambitions d'amazon
de rivaliser par exemple avec netflix
les stratégies qu'on voit à l'oeuvre
actuellement c'est soit des statégies de
fusion deep et concentration
mais qu'est ce que cette transaction
veut dire pour l'avenir du cinéma en
salle je pense pas que le cinéma en
salle va mourir je pense par contre
qu'on va peut-être distribuer moins de
films en salles qu'on va plus faire de
amazon est en train de nous dire compter
avec nous craignez nous c'est exactement
ce qu'a fait dessiner en 2020 c'est ce
que fait amazon en 2021 chains comme
dans un film d'espionnage
la compétition entre les géants du
visionnement en ligne et pleine de
rebondissements et de plus en plus
féroce hasta la vista baby ici
louis-philippe lui-même radio canada bon
rien